Tim we're here today to talk about
broken your latest film which he play a
loving father to a young teenage girl
called skunk but you actually originally
offered a very different part in the
film weren't you tell me a little bit
about that um well I I got in touch with
my it's a mate of mine produced it a
friend of mine produced it Dixie Linda
who produced the film and I did I
directed a long time ago and she's
always doing these really interesting
films and I'm always jealous so I got
caught up somewhat you do yup - and I
move talking and I see well can't read
it and she said to me and oh god he's so
lovely he's such a good guy I really
loved him fell in love with him on the
page you know and and then and and then
you know in the script made me cry it's
beautifully done so I said and it was
cast it was it was cast and then they
came to me with another role which I
which which I didn't want to do I didn't
it it was sort it's done and it's
brilliantly done but it was something
that I very much wanted to see what it
was like to to try and build that that
relationship with that girl and I have
that um I be that kind of character and
something it was something very new to
me and and and it the actor who was cast
in it dropped out at the last minute for
some reason so I got the job fantastic
we're glad you did and he mentioned the
relationship with young girl on the film
of course played by Eloise Lawrence at
first film you've got a very natural on
the screen relationship with her
wondered how you develop that off-screen
I had a very very good experience when I
did a television show I had a girl there
was a guy who played my daughter in
there and Men had developed this rapport
it was just we're just I think was just
to amuse ourselves well anyway yeah and
she was good we always looked forward to
the scenes that she could be a movie
right would write as many as we could
you know to get it right and so it was
kind of useful but when I came to
to do the film I said I'd like to ever
add a I take the kids out and we'll just
go have some lunch and we'll go around
the park and more take photographs and
muck about and just try and get to know
and and the I could see that it was
gonna happen very quickly that
relationship that we would get on
because it might not light and she might
not like me I was probably she I don't
know if she does it but um but we kind
of got there very very quick she's and
and then we brought that to their their
on their dynamic on on screen so that
the audience would feel the loss when
the when it went away and feel the love
between them you mentioned of course
lying to be there which he had a
daughter on the screen as well but you
have three sons in real life have any
daughters who what's it like when you
have a surrogate daughter on thirds it's
alright but of course she's got a mouth
on her she came right back at me it was
it was good it's not it's a different
thing is not the the the testosterone
thing going on
it's quite but the you know she she had
me wrapped around a little finger which
she's exactly as it should have been I
mean he you know she's go away about
that alien and she and then of course
she would deliver the performance and
performance was worked really well
crafted and yeah put together by her and
the director and they're very clever
very she's a very good actor a very
perceptive actor what kind of tricks is
she using I need to wrap her she didn't
look at me also she I mean I got to the
point where I was overbearing parent you
know and she's roll her eyes could hear
him rolling yeah you work with Phil
Milner he played you certain before
haven't you in skellig was it like
working him again this time and and how
would you describe yourself the dad in
real life um well working a built what
was interesting is when I work with Bill
it was only a few years before and he
was a much younger bill because that
when I've been away it's sprouted you
know and here's this big gangly thing
that could barely make it through a door
you know he's it he was in full kind of
adolescence mode by the time I got back
to him and but it was good because we
had a shorthand and it was and all of it
was kind of based on humor and he was
incredibly good with Eloise
you know because that was her first time
in front of the camera she and then we
figured out pretty quick but so but my
relationship with them is different from
my relationship obviously with my I mean
I have a very good relationship with my
kids but you know it's a film so what we
had to do is an abbreviated version of
you know a real life if you obviously
because you're not a documentary but we
need to to get the audience gripped by
and have them so the audiences are
arriving when we're way into our
relationship where you know the band to
the back and forth you know and all of
that stuff is it's just the habit
exactly it's it's very natural isn't it
yeah now how would you compare do you
think like when you were growing up when
you were kind of Eloise's age and Bill's
age but we there was a group of us that
would roam around the neighborhood get
into trouble there's a similarity I
think there you know about now when I
see it from a parent perspective or an
adult perspective it I can i it's
amazing what we did in the danger we put
ourselves in you know but the so I I can
see the similarities between you know
with the characters and what happens in
the film we can see that the
possibilities of that happening um and
as far as he's concerned I mean she's a
Sheila she plays a piano she writes
songs and she's got beautiful voice I
don't know if that's where she's gonna
want to go or if she's gonna want to go
down the acting Road but certainly if
she does go down the acting Road it's
all there for her I mean she it's a
question of being given good advice and
and being around directors that really
know how to work work with you and and
get the best out of you because she's
got a lot to give she's very I think
she's very very talented actor
you